die weltraumsonde beuter 2 hat ein
äußerst mysteriöse magnetbahn zwischen
unserem sonnensystem und dem
interstellaren raum entdeckt die sonne
ist ja am 20.8 1977 gestartet und erst
letztes jahr hat sie den interstellaren
raum erreichen aber es bleiben auch noch
viele rätsel ungelöst kriegs um science
fiction die spannende science wie das
abonniert den kanal und activity glocke
nur dann verpasst ihr nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen und vielen dank für
euren coolen themenvorschlag der über
unsere telegramm community kam
vielen dank für den vorschlag an zicke
glory hole das ist wirklich irre und
niemand hätte sich das damals träumen
lassen doch mittlerweile sind die beiden
voyager sonden also weiter 1 und 2 schon
fast 42 jahre im all unterwegs beide
sind jetzt in einem bereich des weltalls
unterwegs in denen noch niemals zuvor
ein objekt geflogen ist das vom menschen
erschaffen wurde 2012 war es eine echte
premiere als wolter 1 die sogenannte
heliosheath die oft auch als grenze
unseres sonnensystems bezeichnet wird
denn dahinter beginnt dann laut
definition der interstellaren raum auch
new horizon die sonne ist derzeit auf
dem weg zur grenze unseres sonnensystems
doch diese zu passieren das haben bisher
nur die beiden voyager sonden geschafft
denn dafür müssen nicht nur gigantische
entfernungen überwunden werden sondern
auch die gravitationskraft der sonne
doch am 5 november des vergangenen
jahres 2018 war es dann soweit weiter
zwei hatte die heliosphäre verlassen und
war in den interstellaren raum
eingetaucht dazu twitter die nasa ein
jahr später also anfang des monats
november 2009 10 the fantastic four
continues this week we get to join
interstellar space today fünf papers
publish die teiligen twins findings in
syrien just be on sea bubble create your
son nasa budget nasa weiter vors
november 2001 team fünf forschungsteams
also waren daran beteiligt die messdaten
auszuwerten und haben diese jetzt
präsentiert und die ganze untersuchung
bringt erstaunliche erkenntnisse mit
sich denn den fachleuten ist es nun
möglich die daten von voyager 1 mit den
messungen ihrer schwester sonde zu
vergleichen die studien verraten viele
details wie genau der abschied von ba2
unserem sonnensystem vonstatten ging
dabei hatte die nasa-sonde wohl eine 1,5
astronomische einheiten breite
grenzregion die heliopause passiert eine
astronomische einheit ist der abstand
zwischen der erde und der sonne
hier staut sich der sonnenwind also in
der heliopause und wird langsam hat doch
die daten von voyager 2 unterscheiden
sich von den beobachtungen ihrer
schwester sonde geben sommer 2012 in den
interstellaren raum eingetreten war
damals konnten die nasa sonde in
bestimmten bereichen ein mysteriöses
phänomen beobachten interstellare
material dann dabei in die heliosphäre 1
nach der passage durch die heliopause
gab es extreme turbulenzen vermutlich
ausgelöst durch interaktion zwischen
sonnenwind und interstellaren medium
diese turbulenzen konnten mit hilfe der
messung von co2 aber nicht festgestellt
werden dazu leonard burlager von der
nasa demnach war die von freundschaft
zwei beobachtete heliopause stabil und
dünne im gegensatz zur instabilen und
dickeren heliopause die deutsche eins
durchquerte die ursache für diesen
unterschied steht noch nicht mit letzter
sicherheit fest die forschenden vermuten
aber dass dies möglicherweise mit der
aktivität der sonne zu tun haben könnte
denn die heliopause wurde von ba1
während eines minimums im solaren
aktivitätszyklus passiert da die a2 fand
die passage nah am maximum des zyklus
stadt sprich die dicke der heliopause
hängt von der aktivität der sonne ab es
gibt aber eine weitere erkenntnis die
die beiden sonden ermöglicht haben
demnach scheint die heliosphäre also die
sphäre um unser sonnensystem zumindest
auf einer seite eine symmetrische
kugelform aufzuweisen
diese rückschlüsse ziehen die
forschungsteams aus der tatsache dass
beide raumsonden die grenze der
heliosphäre in fast gleicher distanz
passiert haben beim wollte einst waren
es etwa 121 astronomische einheiten und
bei k2 rund 119 klar ist beide sonden
haben dieselbe halbkugel der heliosphäre
durchquert und diese schräg in
flugrichtung unseres sonnensystems
verlassen damit wird aber auch eine
annahme widerlegt von der fachleute
langer zeit aus gingen nämlich dass der
sonnenwind immer weiter abnimmt je
weiter man in den interstellaren raum
kommt stattdessen zeigen wollte 1 und
voyager 2 dass es dort eine ausgeprägte
grenze
also quasi einen scharfen übergang zum
lokalen interstellaren medium super
spannend auch folgendes ergebnis im
lokalen interstellaren medium liegen die
temperaturen bei achtung 30.000 bis
50.000 kelvin und das übertrifft noch
einmal alle erwartungen der fachleute
die bislang von 15 bis 30.000 kelvin
ausgegangen waren möglicherweise
manövriert die heliosphäre eine art
bugwelle vor sich her durch das
interstellare medium doch die chancen
stehen schlecht dass die beiden sonden
diese noch erreichen und genauer
analysieren können denn bis dahin wird
ihnen vermutlich die energie ausgehen
fachleute gehen davon aus dass die
radioaktiven batterien der sonden noch
etwa fünf jahre reichen werden dazu der
planetenforscher edward stone als die
beiden wortschatz gestartet worden war
das weltraum zeitalter erst 20 jahre alt
niemand hat erwartet dass sie 40 jahre
halten würden eine weitere wirklich
super spannende entdeckung gelangen den
forschenden außerdem durch die
auswertung der daten von voyager 2 denn
die sonne ist offensichtlich auf eine
art magnetwand getroffen
die rede ist von einer magnet barriere
die die kosmische strahlung abschirmt
dazu heißt es in einer der fünf studien
die existenz einer solchen barriere
wurde zwar vorhergesagt aber erst jetzt
haben wir sie nachgewiesen das
magnetfeld in dieser barriere war
stärker als jedes zuvor in der helios
hülle gemessene magnetfeld deutsche 1
hatte diese magnetische waren damals
nicht entdeckt die wohl das eindringen
energiereicher elektrisch geladener
teilchen aus dem interstellaren raum in
die heliosphäre reduziert die daten
klären also viele bisher unbeantwortete
fragen und beweisen auf ein neues dass
die renz region unseres sonnensystems
überaus komplex ist und es sich um ein
hoch dynamisches system handelt doch
natürlich bleiben immer noch viele
rätsel ungelöst leben auf maß schon
längst entdeckt das hat die viking
sonden der nasa schon 1976 gefunden
astro comics tv also das video anklicken
das video anschauen und den kanal us
comics tv abonnieren der ist nämlich
megacool bis dann bleibt dran